I find it difficult to tell stories
about people sometimes but today's guest
has no such problem
I first met Evan Hatfield on a trip to
the Arctic he is a man who somehow has
the ability to de-escalate any argument
or maybe all Canadians can do that I
don't know his channel is called rare
earth and he travels the world telling
human stories Evan it's all yours
on rare earth we like to take symbols
from a country that maybe you've not
been to yet and show how they fit into
the bigger picture of your own life and
because Tom caught me at home I want to
do this on my country on Canada and more
specifically I want to do it on a
sexually repressed hypocritical guilt
ridden prostitute visiting mama's boy
our 10th prime minister there's a good
example of how you don't have to be
great at being a person to be a great
politician
what drives someone to become a
politician to me it always seemed like
such a terrible job nobody likes you and
it really doesn't make as much money as
it seems there isn't even really that
much power in it it's kind of like being
a dentist with bad pay but there is
something you get as a politician that
you can get unlike almost anywhere else
and that's a legacy Canada's wartime
Prime Minister is not a man we all
remember fondly he wrote his PhD thesis
on how Asian people would never be able
to integrate into other societies only
to then watch them integrate into his
society even though he was our wartime
prime minister and he hated the Nazis
because of his love of the occult he
kind of felt like this adolf guy might
be the one to lead Germany to glory a
lifetime bachelor whose only sexual
relations came from prostitutes that he
then beat himself up over he regularly
took advice from the ghost of his dead
mother and potentially even that of his
dead dog there's some other stuff too
but you get the picture that's our most
successful guy William Lyon Mackenzie
King he's dead now
everyone in this story is dead now
except me I guess depending on when you
watch this but at one point he was
candid as longest-serving Prime Minister
he ran the country to the depression and
the Second World War
FDR was president for 12 years but
Mackenzie King was prime minister for 21
and he would have been elected again had
he not aged out by any definition he was
an incredibly successful politician and
that's the heart of this I'm not gonna
bore you with his economic plan I'm not
even gonna clickbait you with his racism
and blind eye towards Hitler because
neither of those were truly the purpose
behind King's civil service they weren't
why he became a politician what I want
to talk to you about is the driving
force of legacy and the value of being
weird now I know what you're thinking
weird isn't a very concise term there's
no scientific definition of weird this
is Tom Scott's channel and weird simply
won't do but he was pretty much
everybody who knew him agreed to the
point that his nickname was weird Willy
he was a firm believer in the occult
going so far as to study his shaving
cream for political omens Churchill and
Roosevelt clearly couldn't stand him
even though he done virtually everything
they'd asked in pictures they look
strained just to be
around him which makes sense he was a
generally uncomfortable guy to be around
between his Norman Bates style
relationship with his mother and is
constantly replacing dead dogs named Pat
with live dogs named Pat he built a name
in Ottawa as one of Canada's most
eccentric men but despite his faults
King was a political mastermind the
voting public didn't really care about
his personality so long as the war
economy and Quebec were all managed well
what they wanted was Canada's promise of
peace prosperity and good government and
King could provide it in spite of his
faults no one would deny that in a time
of incredibly basic polling he always
somehow seemed to understand the will of
the people but I suppose he was built a
bit differently after all the government
is rarely a first choice but for King it
was a calling he believed that his
dreams were visions and he followed them
to him his life's divine purpose was to
restore his family legacy and if it took
ruling the entire country to do so
that's what he was gonna do from a young
age King was obsessed with his famous
grandfather also named William Lyon
Mackenzie just without the King which is
in itself a joke because his defining
moment came in trying to free Canada
from the monarchy so you know no King in
the name you get it in the mid-1800s
with Mackenzie as the Mayor of Toronto
rebels hiding out in the u.s. declared
themselves the Republic of Canada and
invaded their intent was overthrowing
British rule in favor of an independent
state or depending on how the québécois
fared States once free of British
tyranny these states would presumably be
gobbled up by their neighbor to the
south but it wasn't to be Britain won
William Lyon Mackenzie memory and the
Republic he stood for died with little
fanfare he remained in public life but
was essentially forgotten it's possible
he'd remained that way to this day if
not for his grandson and his
grandfather's graveside in Toronto that
weird occult mama's boy began a journey
that would redefine this country it
would redefine the legacy his ancestor
left behind sure it wasn't yet a fire
but his grandfather's rebellion had
sparked something in Canada soon
afterwards we'd be voting for our own
prime minister King would be the tenth
and really his timing was perfect it
would be an American Century and it
didn't take a fortune-teller to see that
Canadians had been warming to the idea
of a new mother country a new
hired abouto at the turn of the 20th
century the Republican ideals that had
driven those rebels less than a hundred
years before were stronger than ever
having been dragged headfirst into World
War one without a vote devastated by
indifferent British generals Canada was
ready to change best friends we may have
won the war but Britain had asked us to
give everything for her everything for a
war that meant nothing in a population
of under 8 million over half a million
of us went to Europe my family died in
Europe the next time we'd vote we had a
leader who wasn't afraid to say no to
Britain to say no to conscription we'd
never be forced into war without a vote
again not for Britain not for our new
friend America mother could no longer
come calling to the people that rate had
died in Ypres but to Mackenzie King it
died with his grandfather those days
were over whether it was through his own
backbone or the will of his voters King
led us into a new era
he saw himself not as a person but as a
vessel for legacy and in turn we voted
for him not as a person but as a vessel
for legacy just ours
not his William Lyon Mackenzie King was
not a good person wasn't been really
good at being a person he was weird
nobody liked him and he died alone but
he changed this country's future because
there's one thing you can get as a
politician unlike anywhere else even if
you're weird and that's a legacy and
that's the point of today's episode the
drive that leads us to glory maybe was
just a case of right place right time
perhaps he was little more than an
expression of the changing national mood
I'm certainly not saying that the key to
good politics is poor behavior or acting
strangely but it worked in its time when
you strip everything away
Mackenzie King's grandfather wanted
Canada in the United States to be
friends a strange man sacrificed his
whole life towards personal ends and as
a result here we are friends a weirdo
may have led us there but it doesn't
really matter who he was and he knew
that because the legacy remains
thanks for listening everybody this is
rare-earth
seasons 1 & 2 of rare-earth are online
Nell from Japan and Cambodia and Evan is
working on season 3 right now
so she'll watch and go subscribe I would
recommend starting with this video about
the last elephant's of Cambodia and
that's it
that's this run of guest videos unless
disaster has struck I will see you next
week